So, could it be that Stitch is the most
awaited movie of this year? Lilo and
Stitch? You don't think so? I don't
think so. Okay. Okay. But I think
Superman would probably be or Mission
Impossible. Oh, yeah. There's also
Mission Impossible coming out this year.
I didn't think this was that popular of
a story. Well, it's quite the universe
ever since it came out. Um, so yeah, new
new Lilo and Stitch movies coming out
soon. It's the uh liveaction version cuz
Disney's been going through all of them
lately. Um, and yeah, I think it's kind
of interesting to look at the story of
Lilo and Stitch. Look, let's look at
where it comes from. And I think we're
going to share some things in this
episode that very few people have picked
up on some Easter eggs and some things
that, you know, it might make you look
at Lilo Stitch a little bit differently.
Let's look at the first clip. This is
where Stitch is created in the original
movie. And so we can see kind of like
the backstory of where he comes from.
[Music]
It's not so easy on the
throat. Oh, can it be? Have I done it?
[Music]
So cute. So fluffy
[Applause]
even. Where did I go
[Music]
wrong? What a relief.
Your name is
626. Isn't that nice? Uh 626. 626. Yes.
Oh wow. Yeah. So this is Dr. Juma Juka.
He is like this crazy scientist guy and
he made a whole bunch of these like
aliens basically because he's from outer
space, right? And uh yeah uh his goal
was to make them all of them evil. And
finally he made this guy experiment
number
626. And so if you look at the Lilo
Sitchwiki, it actually says that his
original primary function is to cause
chaos across the galaxy by destroying
everything he touches. He's designed to
be abnormally strong, virtually
indestructible, super intelligent, and
very mischievous. And the Have you guys
ever heard about where how how Lilo and
Stitch came about? Like what was the
original idea behind it? No. So, this
guy right here, his name is Chris
Sanders. He was work he was actually uh
he actually wrote a book and with like
the throughout the animations and stuff
of Stitch and his original idea was for
Stitch to be sent to live among the
animals. He this guy Chris Sanders also
worked on uh what's that robot movie
that you once did a video on? Wild
robot. Wild robot. So he worked on this
too many years later. So the original
Stitch movie, his idea or his book was
that Spiti Stitch was going to live with
the animals. Oh, okay. And then this guy
from Disney was like, "Well, I don't
know if that's really relatable, you
know, for people because the animal
world is as foreign as the alien world,
so let's put them together with humans."
And because Chris had recently gone to
Hawaii, he was like, "Well, how can I
not just put him in Hawaii then?" So
this was this idea behind it. But he
also talks about how they came about
making this villain that then eventually
had redemptive characters. When Dean and
I, we screened it in Las Vegas and
that's when Michael Eisner saw it and
Dean and I came out and Michael Eisner
was standing there and they said,
"Michael wants to talk to you." And we
went over and he said, "I I like this
movie. I I can't really explain it. It's
hard to, you know, quantify, but I like
it. But it's it's weird, but I like it.
And he kept like, so he was like
struggling. He's like, "This is really
strange, but I liked it." And that is
pretty much all you need to know as far
as like had it been seen by a larger
group early on, they would have said,
"This is bizarre. It doesn't make any
sense. An alien in Hawaii." And and the
other thing was it was the first film
that Disney have made. I don't know if
they I don't know if it may still be the
first film where the villain becomes the
hero. Yep. That was that was an
inspiration. That was the start. I
remember that's the first thing Chris
said to me. Um I said, "I'm I'm really
curious about whether or not we could
pull off a story where we begin with the
villain and we we make him become a
hero." Because the the opposite was the
kind of the standard kind of the
standard structure of a Disney movie up
until that point where constantly
thinking of ways to do in the villain at
the end and in some sort of spectacular
way without making it too gratuitous.
And it's like, why do we always have to
kill the villain? What if we start with
a villain and we redeem him? That being
the inspiration. So, the guy that that
Chris Sanders is talking to is Dean
Deloy, and they co-directed the first
Land Stitch movie together. But, uh,
yeah. What are you guys' thoughts so
far? I mean, it's interesting to have
where they're starting with the villain
and trying to redeem the villain. Mhm. I
mean, that's an interesting take to to
why this story has this weird character
in the beginning. Have you guys heard of
narcissism,
Scotty? What is narcissism? It's really
taking the ideas of the Bible and
flipping it upside down. So, you're
taking the heroes that would
traditionally, in a biblical sense, be
the villains of the Bible and making
them the hero. And so, the Gnostics love
to do that. So basically like the snake
in the Garden of Eden would be the
villain in a traditional sense, but
Gnostics make him the hero, right? Yeah.
And and and um you know, I find that
interesting as you look throughout this
this movie that there's all of those
ideas kind of flipped around in a lot of
ways. Um and yeah, it's uh Disney's
known for this. It's a fascinating
admission. Um, you know, if you're
trying to redeem the villain and that
and he says, "It's, you know, not what
we've been doing." You look at how many
story lines where the hero has to do
questionable things. You know, in the
Little Mermaid, what does she have to
do? She has to disobey her dad and go
against the rules. I mean, in fact, if
you watch some of the the trailers or
YouTube shorts for that, he he says in
the live action one, "You broke the
rules, you know?" Mhm. And here she is
going against against her father, which
is a king essentially. If you look at a
lot of them, they are kings. It's a
princess and her father and a king, and
they're going against each other. And
it's going to get interesting. This is
the exact same setup. The exact same
setup. So, I know we're kind of jumping
ahead here cuz some people who are in
here who are not familiar with this
might be like, "What on earth are you
talking about from that one clip?" No,
no, no. Let's establish this right here.
So, first of all, 1 Peter 5'8, "Be
sober. Be vigilant because your
adversary, the devil, walks around like
a roaring lion seeking who he may
devour. Stitch was definitely created to
be this crazy mon monstrosity that's
going to kill everybody, destroy planet
Earth, destroy the universe, the galaxy,
and he was there to like devour, right?
So, that's kind of just setting the
stage right there. But for anyone who's
not familiar with this, bear with me.
We're going to go through this. So, this
is the next clip here. And now, this is
interesting. It's a court scene on this
planet called Turo. Dr. Jumba Juka is
here and he is being tried. There's an
actual trial happening because he broke
the Galactic Laws. Okay. So, and then
another character gets introduced here.
She is the leader of this Galactic
Federation headquarters. And we'll tell
more talk more about who she is after
this.
[Music]
Read the charges.
Dr. Jumba Juka, lead scientist of Galaxy
Defense Industries. You stand before
this council accused of illegal genetic
experimentation.
How do you plead? Not guilty. My
experiments are only theoretical and
completely within legal boundaries. We
believe you actually created something.
Created something? But that would be
irresponsible and unethical. I would
never
ever make more than one.
What is that monstrosity?
Monstrosity? What you see before you is
the first of a new species. I call it
experiment
626. He is bulletproof, fireproof, and
can think faster than superco computer.
He can see in the dark and move objects
3,000 times his size. His only instinct
to destroy everything it touches.
So it is a monster. Just a little one.
It is an affront to nature. It must be
destroyed. Calm yourself, Captain Gantu.
Perhaps it can be reasoned
with. Experiment
626. Give us some sign you understand
any of this. Show us that there is
something inside you that is good.
[Applause]
naughty.
I didn't teach him that. Place that
idiot scientist under arrest. I prefer
to be called evil genius. And as for
that
abomination, it is the flawed product of
a deranged mind. It has no place among
us. Captain
Gantu, take him away. So interesting.
There's a couple things that that that
terminology that that is, I think,
needing to be brought out here. Um the
fact that he's like, I would not create
because I would be irresponsible. And
then he both lied. Yeah. Both lied. and
then admits that he's okay he's created
this thing and then the fact that it's
called an abomination and I mean those
are you know he he wants to be known as
an evil genius and then they ask it to
show you know something good and then I
guess it says something which we
couldn't understand but it's basically
made everybody throw up throw up be
disgusted angry the guy didn't teach him
that yeah so whatever it was it's pretty
pretty horrible Mhm. And and showed
nothing good here, right? But it's
interesting that it's like this court
scene right up in the galaxy. And yeah,
like he's like, you created this vow
being and we can't even have him around
us anymore. And then they're sentenced
to a prison sentence. So let's look at
this this uh situation here. So it says
the grand council woman was first seen
in a courtroom. So that lady is a grand
council woman. So, there's a courtroom,
there's a
trial, and um they're asking, "Can you
show me something good?" And it's like,
"No, this is evil." There's like they're
giving him a redemptive chance, but
there's like there's no chance for you
to stay here. You You show me only evil.
You cannot even show me anything good.
He is sentenced to a life imprisonment
on a maximum security asteroid. Right?
So, let's look at this planet that
they're on. There we on planeturo. So in
in um some like African lang no
Philippine in a Filipino one of the
Filipino languages it means to educate
to teach. So this grand council woman
this is where she resides and works
right like in this on this spaceship
this planet this area where it's all
about the courtroom and the justice
system and etc etc etc. Also, it says
according to supplementary material,
it's also Stitch's birthplace, which I
find interesting because again, the
situation of the courtroom, the legal
system, justice, right? And then Stitch
is born in this place, which in the
Bible, we know the place that is has the
courtroom, the justice system is heaven.
Where God is, where God also will judge
is throughout the Bible. You can see
that there's going to be a judgment
happening in heaven and it's the exact
same place where Satan when he was still
Lucifer was also created in the same
place. Mhm. So that's an interesting
little detail. Mhm. Now the grand
council woman is called your majesty of
course your highness. She's royalty.
Yeah. Okay. What does the Bible say?
Revelation 19 says and he Jesus has on
his robe and on his thigh a name written
king of king of lord of lords. God is
the highest of the highest and so you
know your highness. Yeah. Yeah.
Absolutely. Uh it's it's all over the
Bible that Jesus is royalty. Yeah. She's
also considered a fair judge. So see
she's a judge in a court system in a
trial. She's royalty. John 5 says for
the father judges no one but has
committed all judgment to the son
meaning Jesus. Mhm. Second Corinthians
says, "For we must we must all appear
before the judgment seat of Christ."
That's a courtroom. That's a court
situation. That each one may receive the
things done in the body according to
what he has done, whether good or bad.
Yeah. And it's interesting they putting
him in the position to like say, "Have
you done something good?" Exactly. Yes.
And Daniel, this is a prophecy as well,
uh, of you see here the ancient of days,
God. It says, "I watched till thrones
were put in place, and the ancient of
days was seated. His garment was white
as snow, and the hair of his head was
like pure wool. His throne was a fiery
flame, its wheels a burning fire. A
fiery stream issued and came forth from
before him. A thousand thousands
ministered to him. 10,000 times 10,000
stood before him. The court was seated
and the books were open." And then
jumping to verse 13. I was watching in
the night visions and behold one like
the son of man, meaning Jesus coming
with the clouds of heaven. He came to
the ancient of days and they brought him
near before him. So this is a court
situation with God and Jesus being
present and they're about to do a uh a
judgment, right? So interesting stuff.
Now it also says the Grand Council woman
wishes to preserve order in the galaxy.
She has moments which she shows mercy.
However, she's being she's all about the
rules. She upholds the law.
Come on. Right. Isn't that fascinating?
Wh why why do you think that's an
interesting aspect, Scotty? Well, I
think it's it's you know, if it's kind
of painted as this um
this ruler of the universe. I mean, you
you just kind of can't help but to apply
that to what we actually know of is in
the universe as the one that establishes
the rules. That was God. And we know
that there's one that breaks the rules
and that's the devil. And you know, we
don't know that much about the universe
um beyond what the Bible tells us, but
it's just interesting that these kind of
follow in the same vein. Yeah. And it's
the typical kind of storyline when it
comes to
narcissism. So, and then lastly, so she
they're talking about the United
Galactic Federation, right? So, she is a
strict member of the Galactic Council.
And at the bottom says, "This includes
the laws of other planets outside the
Galactic Federation." So, here it talks
about what that is. And it is a
government that controls an unknown
number of star system is considered to
be a superpower. It's a government.
Keith, can we consider biblically
speaking that the he heaven is God's
government? Sure. Yeah, that makes
sense. How do we know that? Well, God
has a king. He's a supreme ruler. Mhm.
Um just like you see, I mean, you kind
of see
um let's see, I'm thinking of Star Wars.
You know, when in Star Wars, you have
the rebels and you have the Empire. An
empire is a government controlled by a
single supreme ruler. So really God has
an empire because he's the single
supreme ruler. Um yeah and a rebel is of
course somebody who doesn't go along
with what the government wants. So right
you see the same kind of setup in Star
Wars too. Mhm. And he has a law system
right in place. So that's what
governments have as well there. You know
it's interesting that this unit um this
this agency even has its own law
enforcement with the police just like
real governments have. Right. So
interesting little tidbit there. So
let's see what happens. He's getting
caught by Stitch and and and his creator
are
arrested and Stitch is going to be sent
off to this other planet. Let's see what
happens.
[Music]
Uncomfortable. Oh, good. The council has
banished you to exile on a desert
asteroid. So relax. Enjoy the trip. So
yeah, I mean anytime you see somebody
that's banished and like confined to a
certain certain um place that I mean
that's exactly what happened to Satan
and the angels, right? They were kicked
out of heaven. They were cast out. They
were banished. Mhm. Revelation 12:9. So
the great dragon was cast out. That
serpent of old called the devil and
Satan who deceives the whole world was
cast to the earth and the angels were
cast out with him. And in a sense, this
is repeated at the end of time when
Jesus comes again. He's essentially
banished, right? You know, but but has
his imprisonment here. Yes. When the
earth is destroyed. So, it's kind of,
you know, two banishments, if you will.
Yeah. He'll be, you know, after the
Jesus comes back the second time, he
takes his faithful people to heaven.
There's a thousand years, the Bible says
in Revelation, where Satan is is in, you
know, symbolically chained to the earth
with nothing to tempt. And it's
basically like a desert basically.
There's nothing to do for a thousand
years. So that's interesting. So let's
look at this next clip here. Uh he
escapes. Stitch escapes. He gets out of
this capsule and he he steals a red
spaceship and he tries to flee, but then
he presses some kind of a button that um
basically sends him off to a different
location other than the first planet
that he was going to be exiled to. So
let's take a look.
Where is he? He's still in hyperspace.
Where will he exit? Calculating now.
Quadrant 17, section 005, area 51. A
planet called the Earth. I want an
expert on this planet. In here now.
What is that? Water. Most of the planet
is covered in it. He won't survive in
water. His molecular density is too
great.
[Music]
No.
Of
course. Do you hear? There was like a
little maybe Easter egg in there when
they said what area he was confined to.
Was it Did they say it was like Area 51
North? Yeah, they said Area 51 as well.
Yeah, that's funny. Wait, did they say
Area 51? They said Area 51. They said
Area 51. Really? Yeah, they did. Yeah.
So, that's that's kind of funny. I guess
they were already dealing with that kind
of stuff back. Hawaii is the the garden
island. It's the you know the like the
island. Yeah. Well, very interesting
that I they film a lot of movie stuff
there. Yes. But it's also known as a
paradise and they actually say this. So
interesting. Very interesting.
Hey, subscribe to Lea Studios.
If you want to learn Spanish, a great
way will be watching our videos for
practice. Lilo, she is in her bedroom
and she kind of gets bullied. This is
she's living with her sister, right? Her
parents have passed away and she gets
bullied a lot by the kids and she's
like, I just really want a friend. Let's
see what happens.
A falling star.
I call it. Get out. Get out. I have to
make a wish. Can't you go any faster? Oh
no. Gravity is increasing on me. No,
it's not. It is too, Lilo. The same
thing happened yesterday.
You rotten sister. Your butt is crushing
me. Why do you act so weird?
It's me again. I need someone to be my
friend. Someone who won't run
away. Maybe send me an
angel. The nicest angel you have.
I mean, it's Yeah. you can't help but to
to point out the obvious that you know
there was somebody that was confined to
a paradise that was an angel. Yeah. It's
like how obvious does it get? Oh, like
lightning from Yeah, this is true. This
is also in the Bible. When it says
angel, it shows you what type of angel.
Revelation 12:9 says, you know, Satan
was cast out with all of his angels like
and and the Bible is clear. Satan was an
angel. Yeah. He was just a fallen angel,
right? Because he was the one who was he
or sin originated with him and
destruction and evil and all those kind
of things. Interesting little seed here.
She is praying for something, you know,
and and you know, this thing comes their
way. People oftentimes correlate things,
you know, because they pray and
something happens like, well, this is
probably an answer to my prayer.
Probably not always. Yeah, you got to be
careful. And I find it interesting, too.
We've done a couple of videos and and a
documentary about aliens. I personally
have a conviction that when you see
aliens or alien manifestations, it's
demonic manifestations. Yes, absolutely.
100%. And interesting that we did
something that that was talking about
them being blue and it's quite kind of
interesting that right this alien is
blue. This is true. We have a whole
video on that too about how there's
frequently when you see demonic
characters in movies and ghosts and
spirits they are blue and now he is
blue. We'll leave the links for that on
the description. Yeah. Make let people
make their own mind on that one.
Okay. So, uh, you talked about paradise,
right? Look at this ad for Lilo and
Stitch on the Disney Channel. His name
is Stitch. She lives in paradise, a
falling star, and he's from out of
space. What is that thing? Paradise,
fallen star. Interesting that um, is it
Revelation 12:4 that says, "His tail
drew a third part of the stars of heaven
and did cast them to earth." Mhm. That
was Revelation 12. Yeah. Yeah. And what
are those stars represent? Stars are
fallen angels. Yep. Yeah. And she says,
"A fallen star and it's imperative."
This is not anybody who made this ad.
This is Disney Channel who made the
movie. Disney made the movie and now
Disney Channel made the ad. Yeah, they
know what they're talking
about. So now he after he uh falls from
the sky on lands on planet Earth, he
come crawls out of those bushes. He gets
hit by a truck and the people in the
truck are like, "What is this?" I guess
it's a dog, maybe. Let's take him to the
animal shelter. This is where Lilo meets
Stitch for the first time.
Hello.
Hello. Are there any animals in
here? Hello?
[Music]
Hi.
How?
Wow.
Oh, yes. Mhm. All of our dogs are
adoptable, except that one. What is that
thing? A dog, I think. But it was dead
this morning. It was dead this morning?
Well, we thought it was dead. And it was
hit by a truck. I like him. Come here,
boy.
[Music]
Wouldn't you like a different dog? We
have better dogs, dear. Not better than
him. He can talk. Say hello.
Dogs can't talk, dear. He did. Does it
have to be this dog?
Yes, he's good. Does this parallel some
kind of a story in the Bible?
Mhm. Uh maybe when Satan came and he
disguised himself as a snake in order to
deceive the woman. It says that the
snake was really pretty. Yeah. Pretty
cunning. Mhm. Used the appearance of the
snake to lure Eve in. At the time, she
was called the woman, right? That would
be a little weird if it was a snake.
Yeah. Well, think about it. It's
basically like this creature from other
an other earthly creature that was not
native, you know, and then speaks to the
woman and it's like they even noticed
this on the Lelo and Stitch wiki seeing
the little girl as an unaware hostage.
626 altered his appearance to look less
otherworldly and posed as a dog in order
for her to adopt him. He looked at the
picture of a girl with a dog and he's
like, "Oh, I guess I'll do that." Mhm.
That should trick him. Mhm. So, he
tricks her. Interesting. So, anyway, so
um let's skip to the end of the movie.
So, you see the Grant Council woman here
and they finally caught Stitch cuz they
want to make sure he goes to do his
punishment to
exile. And she has mercy on him. Of
course. If it wasn't for your experiment
626, none of this stitch. What? My name
Stitch. Stitch. Then if it wasn't for
Stitch, does Stitch have to go in the
ship?
Yes. Can Stitch say
goodbye? Yes. Thank you.
[Music]
Who are
you? This is my family. I found it all
on my
own. It's little and broken, but still
good. Yeah, still good.
[Music]
Does he really have to go?
You know as well as I that our laws are
absolute. I cannot change what the
council has decided.
Lilo, didn't you buy that thing at the
shelter?
[Music]
Hey, three days ago I bought Stitch at
the shelter. I paid $2 for him. See the
snap? I own them. If you take them,
you're stealing.
Aliens are all about rules.
You look familiar.
CIA Roswell, 1973.
Ah, yes. You had hair. Then take note of
this. This creature has been sentenced
to life in exile. A sentence that shall
be henceforth served out
here on
Earth. And as caretaker of the alien
life form, Stitch, this family is now
under the official protection of the
United Galactic Federation.
We'll be checking in.
Interesting. What' you guys hear about
the laws? Yeah. Like absolute. Absolute.
They can't break the laws. Mhm. So, look
at it this way,
right? She is the judge. She's the grand
council
woman. She is the one that is all about
the law and imposes the laws. She wants
order in her like galaxy, I guess.
And she's like, "The laws are absolute,
meaning they cannot be changed." It's
exactly what the Bible says as well. And
then there's this little girl comes with
this two little pamphlet of $2 and like
I with my human laws can succeed your
laws. Interesting. And then she says,
"Well, he's going to remain in exile on
planet Earth forever." And also they
portray him as that this girl has been
able to change Stitch and now he's
become good. Mhm. So it was a really
like wholesome scene. It was made to be
really like feel like a sympathiz.
So what does the Bible say about the
law? Psalms says the works of his hands
are varity and justice. All his precepts
are sure. They stand fast forever and
ever and are done in truth and
uprightness. And then Psalm 89, my
covenant, which by the way, if you look
at Hebrews 8, the covenant is is
frequently in in in many contexts is
actually referred to the ten
commandments. I will not break nor alter
the word that has gone out of my lips.
And Matthew 5 says, do not think, this
is Jesus' words, do not think that I
came to destroy the law of the prophets.
I did not come to destroy but to
fulfill. For surely I say to you, till
heaven and earth pass away. One jot or
one tit will by no means pass in the law
till all was fulfilled. As far as I
know, we're still here on planet Earth,
so these laws are still valid. And uh
yeah, interesting then that this is what
they talk about in um Lilo and Stitch
that they try to change the laws and
she's like, I guess I can make an
exception. Yeah. It's almost like the
the little girls coming to the place
where it's like I purchased him, you
know, and it's like uh he's now mine
supersedes anything that like like he
was created, he does evil things. He
was, you know, bad in the universe, so
to say. And it's like really that just
like cleared all that just because the
little girl bought it. Yeah. Well, and
then in in
narcissism, you have uh Lilith as well.
And so Lilith is the one who actually
starts a relationship with Satan, with
Lucifer, and they kind of go off
together and do their thing together.
So, kind of interesting. Yeah. I'm
pretty sure Lilith is
also in place of Eve. Like, it's like
Adam and Lilith instead of Adam and Eve.
Right. Right. But of course, Stitch does
not stay good. In fact, in the third
film, which was technically Little and
Stitch 2, it was like a like a a
follow-up of Lil Stitch one.
Third film. Yeah, that was the second.
This is the third installment, but it
was like it was called Little and Stitch
2. Oh, okay. Yeah. So, it was like
following up on Little Lo and Stitch
movie. So Stitch is having nightmares
about turning bad again and causing
destruction to Earth, including her
hurting
Lilo. And it seems that after Stitch was
created, Jumba did not get a chance to
fully charge Stitch's molecules as he
was arrested by the intergalactic police
who disrupted the process. At first,
this glitch causes Stitch to revert to
his old destructive programming, but it
will ultimately destroy him if Jumba
cannot create a fusion chamber before
Stitch's energy runs out for good. So,
let's take a look at this second part of
the movie or second film of Leela and
Stitch and and see what this what
happens when he glitches.
Look out.
Stitch, get out here.
What are you doing?
That's not what we practice.
Hero can't control your
dog. Hero.
Does he look good?
So, there's going to be some sort of
secondary redeeming him from this evil
that he's probably Yeah. Yeah. That's
basically what they're trying to do.
Yeah. So, but yeah, you know, I I find
this fascinating. Revelation 20 says,
"The devil who deceived them was cast
into the lake of fire and brimstone, and
they will be tormented day and night
forever and ever." This is the final
ending of Satan, how it's going to end
up with him, where sin and Satan will be
destroyed, and they will be gone
forever. Not that it keeps regenerating.
Yeah. Not that it keeps going. And
that's that's the the theme of Lucifer,
right? That you see in in everywhere in
the new age, in Satanism,
um in um movies and in music. It's
always this theme of like Satan is going
to win this battle between good and
evil, and we're all going to live
happily ever after between quotation
marks on earth doing whatever you want
to do under evil, but we're going to be
happy doing it. That's his version of
the story. Whereas God's like, nuh-uh,
it's going to get destroyed. This will
be you're destroyed ending at this point
and never to rise again. Yeah. Yeah. And
so we see this kind of gnostic theme
over and over and over again. And uh
yeah, like again, crazy story that this
is how it ends. Like, oh, this person
who is very much almost symbolic of God
is like, no, never mind. You could just
stay here on Earth forever. Yeah, we'll
check in on you. Yeah, we'll check in on
you later. Yeah, I think if anybody got
to this point and and has seen all of
this and hopefully it planted a seed of
like, you know what, I've never heard
this before. Definitely check out our
other videos because uh we have a lot of
videos on our channel regarding cartoons
and and Gnostic movies. In fact, I'll
put a link in the description even of a
talk you once did about the Gnostic
Gospels and you went into it a little
bit more. But you know what does the
Bible say about these things about
watching these kind of movies about
allowing these kind of stories to enter
our minds? Philippians says, "Finally,
brethren, whatever things are true,
whatever things are noble, whatever
things are just, whatever things are
pure, whatever things are lovely,
whatever things are of good report, if
there's any virtue, and if there's
anything praiseworthy, meditate on these
things, the things which you learned and
received and heard and saw in me, these
do, and the God of peace will be with
you." Um, I didn't grow up a Christian.
I watched the first Lilo and Stitch
movie. Don't remember a lot about it.
And then I watched it. I was like, "Oh,
yeah. I I remember these little bits and
pieces here." But you know, once Christ
comes into your heart, he wants to give
you a new heart. He wants to transform
you. He wants to change you. And he
wants to show you how he really is his
true self. And we can find that in the
scriptures, in the Bible, what God is
really like. But Satan is smart, smarter
than all of us. And he knows if I can
just plant a little seed here, a little
deception there, a little bit here, then
slowly but surely I can change the way
God's people think about God. Right? And
so to think that Satan wouldn't use the
most powerful tool in the whole world,
which is Hollywood and the music
industry, it just would be a smart
choice if the devil were to use one of
the most influential businesses, you
know? Yeah. I mean, wouldn't you if you
had a plan to change everybody's minds
and turn them against somebody and you
were like evil like that, of course you
would use that tool, right? Yeah. And
so, yeah, I just wanted to throw this
out there as a word of caution, you
know, seek God, seek his scriptures,
seek his word, and um and just be aware
there's a roaring lion out there seeking
whom he may devour.
And we can choose today whom we will
serve. A story is a very powerful medium
to um to change somebody's mind. I mean,
we know that, you know, people are one
to the gospel all the time because they
hear the story of Jesus. And I think
that the devil is just counterfeiting
that and he's telling his version of the
story. And so, you know, which story do
you really want to be paying attention
to? You know, the story that leads you
to a belief in God or a story that gives
you sympathy for the devil and his
cause. Yeah. And even if for some reason
people think, well, I don't pick up on
all these symbols that you're putting
out here, so it's not influencing me.
Sure, that's somebody can say that. But
there's little nuances here that even if
you're a child or whether you're an
adult, you're being shown. Like for
example where the the grant council
woman at the end is like well our laws
are absolute but then she goes against
her laws. Little things the laws don't
matter. They're they're not everlasting.
Humans can change the God's laws right
and so I think that there's a reason why
it is put in these movies. And in fact
if you go to IMDb there's a whole list
that secular people have written up that
shows which movies are gnostic. So, it's
known. This is this is a known concept
in Hollywood. It's not a grand secret,
though sometimes it is still kind of
under the table. Um, this is a real
thing. And, you know, let's let's let's
turn our hearts to Jesus. Let's focus on
him because he's coming soon and we want
to be ready for that. If you like this
video, like, subscribe, and hit the
notification bell so you know when we
launch new videos and drop a comments
below and we'll try to get back to you
if we can.
What?
Say that again. No. No. I don't know
what to say.